when kobe was born in august kelsey
couldn't be there to hold him
at 29 weeks pregnant she'd become
seriously unwell with covid
she was placed into an induced coma and
woke up to discover her son had been
delivered
i can't quite get my head around
what's actually happened like being told
it and being told other people's
experience and
like family members whilst i was in the
coma and everything is quite hard to
hear
kelsey was unvaccinated a decision she
now regrets
if anyone was told that they would be
put into a coma and potentially dying i
think you'd probably consider it a lot
more um
but yeah i think i'm i'm going to get it
now
recent figures show almost 20 of
critically ill covered patients are
unvaccinated pregnant women
we know that if you get
covered in pregnancy especially later in
pregnancy there is a risk that you may
get a more serious uh form of covid you
may be admitted to the hospital you can
have the vaccine at any stage during
pregnancy i've got increasing amount of
data that tells us that it does not
increase the risk of miscarriage it does
not increase the risk of still birth and
it does not increase the risk of
prematurity
data shows contracting covert during
pregnancy can increase the chance of a
premature birth
olivia was hospitalized with covert in
december when the vaccine wasn't
available
a scan shortly after showed her baby had
stopped growing
and there was very low levels of
amniotic fluid which then basically
means that
you know the baby could be still born so
at that point they then said we're going
to
induce you so within 48 hours of making
that decision they took me into hospital
and i was induced and dude was born at
39 weeks
decisions may be emotionally complex but
the advice is clear
pregnant people can and should get
vaccinated
it doesn't increase risks but may avoid
heartbreak
jeremiah milwaukee sky news